[Musique]
bonjour nouveau numéro de pourvu que ça
dure les missions qui rend les
co-responsables sur public sénat
aujourd'hui on parle de nos déchets
alimentaires ménagers et électroniques
avec la crise sanitaire nos déchets se
multiplient comme jamais certains comme
les déchets métalliques peuvent être une
réponse vous le verrez aux pénuries de
matières premières que nous vivons
actuellement le plastique est l'un des
plus gros fléau pour la nature et les
océans alors peut-on imaginer une vie
avec un plastique recyclé à l'infini
reportage dans cette émission batteries
électriques et déchets ménagers eaux
usées antoine frérot le pdg de veolia
nous expliquera comment c'est quasiment
tous recyclés mais d'abord tout ce qu'il
faut savoir en matière de déchets en
moins d'une minute c'est parti déchets
de quoi on parle juste chaque année nous
produisons 326 millions de tonnes de
déchets 5 tonnes par habitant le secteur
de la construction est le plus gros
producteur avec 224 millions de tonnes
suivie par les entreprises qui en
émettent 63 millions et enfin les
ménages qui en produisent 39 millions
mais tous les déchets ne se ressemblent
pas il ya les déchets dangereux par
exemple les équipements électriques et
électroniques les piles les aérosols les
résidus de peintures les solvants les
insecticides il représente 3 % des
déchets les 97 % restants sont non
dangereux le verre le carton de
plastique peuvent être recyclés les
déchets de jardin où les restes de repas
sont biodégradables
certaines ordures ménagères peuvent être
utilisés comme combustible pour produire
de la chaleur ou de l'électricité
c'est la valorisation énergétique
les déchets issus du btp comme le béton
ou les briques ne produisent aucune
réaction et peuvent être réutilisés sur
d'autres chantiers mais au fait que
deviennent nos déchets 6% servent à la
valorisation énergétique 28% sont
éliminés et 66% sont recyclés
la crise sanitaire at elle changé notre
regard sur les déchets on en parle avec
vous abderrhamane el aoufir bonjour moi
je vous êtes le directeur général de
dérisoire environnement on parle ici
maintenant des déchets métalliques c'est
votre métier donc nos vieilles voitures
nos vieux frigo on en produit 14
millions de tonnes par an en france
c'est beaucoup par 14 millions 14
millions c'est le la quantité produite
chaque année à peu près de déchets
métalliques métal déchets métalliques
qui sont produites chaque année en
france c'est l'équivalent peu près de 14
millions de des véhicules deux voitures
voilà certainement on en vend 2 millions
ça fait cette année de ventes cette
année devant d'une voiture il sauf que
tous ses biens de consommation en fin de
vie vous voulez recyclé mais ces déchets
métalliques aujourd'hui valent de l'or
vous le savez avec les prix des matières
premières qui flambent les matériaux
c'est alors tout bénef pour vous les
matières premières et d'un métier qui
est très cyclique les prix varient en
fonction de l'offre et de la demande
aujourd'hui c'est au aujourd'hui c'est
très haut parce que avec la crise
sanitaire il ya eu un décalage entre
l'offre et la demande les usines sont
arrêtés et puis dans la crise pendant la
crise et puis après la demande est
repartie et bien reparti et il n'y avait
pas suffisamment de matières premières
et donc voilà il ya la demande étant
supérieure à l'offre les prix ont monté
voilà on parle beaucoup des justement
des pénuries de composants de matériaux
le recyclage de nos frigos de machines à
laver ou de la voiture c'est une réponse
aussi quelque part face à ses problèmes
de pénurie de matière
alors il ya deux façons de produire de
l'acier et à un produit de l'acier à
partir du minerai dont on comprend du
minerai de fer du cocan produit de
l'acier et à une le deuxième procès
décès de produire à partir des
ferrailles recyclées ce qu'on appelle la
filière électrique il il va de soi que
cette filière électrique va se trouver
je dirais beaucoup plus favorisés parce
que la crise sanitaire a été un
accélérateur de tendance est donc la
dimension environnementale a pris
beaucoup de place est donc aujourd'hui
les sidérurgistes nos clients
sidérurgistes
ils sont tous en train de réfléchir
comment produire de l'acier à partir de
la filière électrique et à partir de
ferrailles de recyclage
donc et c'est une bonne chose à la fois
pour la planète pour pour nous donc le
déchets métalliques et vu de plus en
plus comme une matière première
secondaire c'est ce sentiment c'est une
matière et studios de matières premières
issues du recyclage voilà quels sont les
déchets métalliques les plus recherchés
aujourd'hui par vos clients les
industriels c'est quoi c'est le le
cuivre l'acier parce qu'on voit les
cours qui flambent alors on fait la
distinction entre ce qu'on appelle
ferraille pour schématiser c'est tout ce
qu'ils pourront aller mans et tout ce
qui est non ferreux comme le cuivre le
plan l'aluminium le bronze de l'étang
d'accord aujourd'hui je dirais que tout
est demandé un il n'y a pas de
différence sauf que les métaux non
ferreux sont à des prix beaucoup plus
élevés que ce qu'est la ferraille pour
donner un ordre d'idée aujourd'hui la
ferraille on va être entre 350 et 400
euros la tonne le cuivre on est plutôt
entre
7000 7900 euros la tonne un décor donc
c'est les secteurs qui achètent c'est
quoi ce sont les constructeurs
automobiles les le bâtiment bat les
producteurs d'acier alors nos clients ce
sont les sidérurgistes pour ce qui est
ferraille pour produire de l'acier et
les métallurgistes pour ce qui est des
métaux non ferreux les sidérurgistes
produisent houde ce qu'on appelle les
produits plats à savoir la voiture la
voiture est le principal consommateur ou
par exemple les réfrigérateurs les
machines à laver ou les produits longs
les produits lancés pour la construction
sans les poutrelles des cornières ça
coûte combien de recycler un
réfrigérateur
alors aujourd'hui il ya le coût de
recyclage en soit c'est à peu près 1 300
euros la tonne ce qui fait à peu près 15
euros le réfrigérateur sachant qu'un
réfrigérateur et d'un poids moyen de 50
kg d'accord après il ya la revendre et
où le revendre et combien ça vous coûte
300 euros la tonne c'est ça c'est le lui
le coût de revient le prix de revient
d'accord donc ça c'est les
amortissements le personnel énergie le
fait de recycler la corde le frigo après
il ya quand vous le revendez ou le
revendre à combien alors ça c'est
différent
il ya différentes composantes dans le
réfrigérateur il ya de la ferraille il
ya des métaux non ferreux en moyenne
maintenant oui alors on peut dire
aujourd'hui où 400 450 mais le problème
il faut savoir que nous on achète on n'a
pas honte de dire quand les prix
augmentent
c'est pas comme si on avait un puits de
pétrole quand les prix augmentent on
augmente aussi nos prix d'achat il faut
récupérer des affligés rateur voilà
avait tué le plus cher nous vous livrons
plus cher ouais on les bons plus cher
mais on les achète aussi plus cher est
ce que la crise sanitaire a changé un
petit peu notre regard sur justement sur
les déchets métalliques même au delà de
ça du côté à la fois des consommateurs
des industriels on s'est rendu compte
que tout ça était utile qu'il y avait
une seconde vie c'était vertueux pour la
planète et en plus c'était rentable
alors pour nous on fait on continue de
faire toujours le même métier le
recyclage des déchets métalliques
c'est au niveau de nos clients qui sont
rendus compte aujourd'hui avec la des
chronos décarbonation de l'économie
qu'il fallait changer de méthode on ne
peut plus travailler à partir du minerai
qu'il fallait donner la priorité à aux
matières premières secondaires issues du
reçu aussi que l'âge est donc pour nous
c'est c'est une comédie est une bonne
chose puisque on est assuré d'avoir la
demande sera toujours là donc notre
métier si vous voulez existera toujours
après ce qu'il faut c'est quand on lance
un produit fabriqué avec des métaux très
en amont il faut penser à son recyclage
dès le début c'est ça aussi la clé no
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'éco conception
donc aujourd'hui on apprend de plus en
plus d'accord alors on trop lentement
aujourd'hui on peut réduire que
pratiquement elle n'existe pas avec le
démarrage des des rep ça veut dire la
responsabilité élargie des producteurs
on espère qu'avec les producteurs on
s'assoit autour d'une table et de leur
dire voilà qu'il faut pas mélanger trop
de produits dans un dans une seule
machine parce que après il faut penser à
leur recyclage et pour ne pas polluer
rien que dans une voiture il ya des
dizaines et des dizaines de sortes de
plastiques pour séparer ses plastiques
compte relier des plastiques qui 100
recyclable à 100% iliad d'autres qui ne
le sont pas et c'est très difficile de
les séparer on n'a jamais fini là dessus
on n'a jamais autant recyclé aujourd'hui
les déchets ces déchets ce traitement
des déchets qui explose essaie de nous
quand il fait une bonne nouvelle pour la
planète oui tout le monde a pris
conscience qu'il fallait recycler tout
le monde donc de plus en plus on va
aller chercher le dernier point du
déchets métalliques on va le avants ont
laissé par exemple deux ou trois points
qui partait en centre d'enfouissement ou
d'incinération donc aujourd'hui les
exigences sont très strictes et on va
chercher le dernier point de mettre
métalliques dans des chais c'est une
bonne chose pour la planète bon voila
merci à thé rahmane el aoufir directeur
général de dericquebourg environnement
merci merci beaucoup le plastique est
une catastrophe pour l'environnement
mais heureusement de plus en plus de
solutions existent pour le recycler
manuel aigre les déchets plastiques
s'accumulent sur notre planète en six
ans les industriels en ont produit près
de 7 milliards de tonnes dont 80% ont
fini dans des décharges dans la nature
mais aussi dans nos océans
et la pandémie a considérablement
aggravé la situation
avec 8 millions de tonnes
supplémentaires de déchets plastiques
une situation alarmante qui empire
chaque jour dans les années 50 la
planète produit 2 millions de tonnes de
plastique et atteint 450 millions de
tonnes en 2015 aujourd'hui dans le monde
un million de bouteilles plastiques sont
vendues chaque minute alors comment
faire face à ces déchets qui pullulent
sur notre planète
à bayonne chez suez
olivier et ses équipes donnent une
seconde vie à 30 mille tonnes de
bouteilles plastique chaque année cette
usine traite les bouteilles qui sortent
des centres de tri pour en faire des
paillettes qui seront ensuite réutilisés
dans les bouteilles neuves
il s'agit du recyclage mécanique le
principe est simple
olivier récupère les bouteilles en
plastique usagées les broie jusqu'à
obtenir des paillettes à partir de ça il
peut recréer de nouveaux objets mais
olivier ne sait recycler qu'un type de
plastique le pays hôte est celui qui est
à base de polyéthylène est très présent
dans l'emballage alimentaire alors pour
le repérer dans cet amas de détritus il
fait confiance aux nouvelles
technologies
le trait aux tic c'est quoi ce sont des
caméras infrarouge qui permet de
reconnaître la matière dans laquelle il
fait la bouteille et nous on va
conserver que la matière en pe t
une fois ces bouteilles identifiés par
les caméras infrarouges nettoyé puis
broyés elles sont empaquetés dans ces
sacs et vendues aux industriels pour une
seconde vie si on parle de rendement
matière quand on rentre sans qui nos à
l'entrée le sinn on va ressortir 70 kg
environ 2 pt de paillettes peu était
prête à être réutilisé un rendement
élevé mais qui aurait ses limites
nous avons rendez-vous à clermont
ferrand chez cardios les spécialistes de
la chimie verte et selon le directeur
général martin stefan le recyclage
mécanique et d'un ancien temps ils
prennent d imaginer des déchets
plastiques comme des bouteilles il les
broie il les fondent et ils refont des
granulés qui vont permettre de fabriquer
à nouveau des bouteilles problème c'est
que pour fabriquer une bouteille
transparente à base de plastique recyclé
il faut utiliser comme déchets des
bouteilles transparentes donc déjà c'est
assez limité ensuite ce cycle peut-être
fait six ou sept fois mais pas beaucoup
plus parce qu'à la fin le produit a été
trop fondu et trop coupé et donc n'a
plus les qualités nécessaires pour
fabriquer les bouteilles martin se
défend nous reçoit dans son usine
expérimentale de recyclage dans un lieu
tenu secret
grâce à son procédé révolutionnaire
ils ne seraient plus soumis à ces
contraintes et pourrait répéter
l'opération à l'infini avec nos
technologies tous ces déchets plastiques
que ce soit des mélanges de bouteilles
transparentes coloré opaque des mélanges
de textile polyester comme celui ci ou
des mélanges de bouteilles transparentes
comme celui là grâce à notre technologie
à base d'enzymes
on est capable de fabriquer du pt dans
du polyester que ce soit pour fabriquer
des bouteilles ou que ce soit pour
fabriquer des fibres et ça on va le
faire autant de fois qu'on veut
vêtements en fibres bouteilles
emballages martin parvient grâce à une
enzyme à récupérer sans les détériorer
les molécules d'origine de ces
plastiques pet est aujourd'hui usagers
il les transforme en plastique pe des
vierges sous forme de petites billes
blanches un système vertueux et écolo
qui permet à l'infini de fabriquer sans
avoir recours à la pétrochimie
[Musique]
c'est plus cher forcément mais malgré ça
la plupart des grands donneurs d'ordres
de péter pour l'emballage se sont tous
engagés à utiliser de plus en plus de
plastique recyclé dans leur emballage
pour embarquer l'ensemble de la société
dans sun dans un nouveau mouvement une
nouvelle c'est une nouvelle économie et
ils sont prêts à payer un surcoût pour
ses emballages cardios ouvrira en 2025
sa première usine de recyclage à grande
échelle une innovation prometteuse mais
qui a ses limites puisque cette usine ne
s'attaquera copé ôté et non aux autres
plastiques
[Musique]
plastiques batteries électriques eaux
usées déchets ménagers le marché du
recyclage est très prometteur est une
bonne nouvelle pour la planète antoine
frérot besoin d'avis ça va très bien p
dg de veolia installez-vous en revanche
ce qui n'est pas une bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'en france seulement 28% du
plastique et recycler c'est trop peu
évidemment pourquoi est ce que est ce
qu'on y est pourquoi est-ce qu'on est à
la traîne parce qu'on est à la traîne
quand on se compare par rapport aux
européens oui parce que dans l'eau au
niveau mondial c'est moins de 10% mais
non alors ce 28% il est pas suffisant
mais il progresse puisque c'était 24 %
il ya deux ans la raison pour laquelle
on est seulement 28 % c'est que on n'a
pas encore assez d'utilisateurs de
plastique recyclé pour fabriquer de
nouveaux objets en plastique
parce que les industriels du plastique
avaient leurs propres mécanismes de
production et virginie anti peut il
refuser un petit peu utilisé du
plastique recyclé ils sont peut-être
trop lent on va dire mais ça progresse
et de la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'en 2021
justement on va encore monter et l'année
prochaine encore davantage oui parce que
le plastique recyclé ça peut coûter
encore plus cher que la résine vierge
même si avec le prix des hydrocarbures
qui montent beaucoup ça va sans doute un
moment s'inverser mais ça monte
progressivement c'est vrai que les 28 %
on en collecte et en ont pris plus que
28% veolia a multiplié par quatre depuis
cinq ans ces unités de recyclage du
plastique mais nous n'avons pas encore
assez de clients pour acheter statique
recycler ça va venir très
progressivement bafin je pense que dans
quelques années on sera 40 % la france
est engagée à tendre vers 100 % à 40 %
et 100 % de plastique recyclé en 2025
est ce que c'est mission impossible
parce que l'objectif suis pas un expert
n'a pas l'air très très contraignant
c'est une ambition les ans la ressent
bien évidemment et donc ce constat qui
vaut loi mais pourtant recyclé 100% il
faudrait que
peut-être inciter voire peut-être
contraindre ceux qui utilisent du
plastique tous les ans à en mettre de
plus en plus donc il faudrait un cadre
réglementaire plus strict sur les usages
du plastique recyclé recyclés par les
industriels commentaire ou un tit hâtif
un
nom mais les deux fonctionnent vous
savez si si le plastique recyclé coûte
moins cher le petit vierge si pollué
coûte plus cher que ne pas polluer c'est
ainsi d'aller voir les acteurs tout de
suite bien évidemment ces lignes ifs et
je pense que progressivement c'est ça
qui va venir se mettre en place vous
produisez des cartes sim puisqu'on parle
de recyclage du plastique les cartes sim
à base de plastique recyclé notamment
issus des réfrigérateurs on en produit
quatre milliards et demi dans le monde
des cartes sim donc le business il est
énorme oui mais pas vraiment des cas la
1ère cat recyclé est donc là aussi c'est
un état démarrage c'est un début le
plastique de les réfrigérateurs
effectivement c'est le même plastique
qu'on utilise dans les dents les cartes
sim et donc c'est pour ça que c'est de
là qu'on leur cycle là aussi on est au
début d'un processus
mais effectivement
dans quelques années ça sera un milliard
puis 2 milliards et un jour on arrivera
au 4 milliards de cartes sim chaque
année avec du plastique recyclé et pas
seulement du plastique d'ailleurs mais
également d'autres produits antoine
frérot est ce que vous consommez des
yaourts ça m'arrive bon vous me voyez
venir en consomme 130 daoud par an et
par habitant et la plupart des pots de
yaourt ne sont jamais recyclé le plus
souvent ils sont incinérés ou enfouis
est-ce que c'est trop complexe à
recycler ou est-ce que économique on
sait pas assez rentable pour les
recycleurs de le faire vous savez qu'il
existe de nombreuses sortes de
plastiques
plus d'une centaine
cinq types de plastiques représentent
80% du plaisir qu'on utilise les pots de
yaourt c'est pas dans les cinq c'est du
pvc est donc aujourd'hui on sait
techniquement très mal le recycler et
c'est pourquoi ça peut paraître bizarre
parce que le plastique des bouteilles
d'eau on sait très bien recycler ceux
des bouteilles de shampoing ceux des
pare chocs de voitures par exemple mes
mains ne met pas les podiums par encore
pourquoi parce que dedans il ya des des
molécules qui sont très complexes
à recycler afin de refabriquer une
résine plastique qui donne les mêmes
qualités techniques donc un but sur une
grande technique pour l'instant oui on
parle de la voiture électrique antoine
frérot pourquoi parce qu'avec l'essor
des ventes de voitures faudra dans
quelques années 2030 est un avant
recycler des millions de batteries écrit
millions dans le monde évidemment
sachant qu'une batterie votre retirer
d'un véhicule quand elle perd 30% en
gros de sa performance et la bonne
nouvelle c'est que 90% de ces matériaux
d'une batterie trick on sait on peut
théoriquement on peut théoriquement les
recycler comme on peut on le fait déjà
figurez-vous pour les peu de batterie
électrique qui arrivent en fin de vie
puisqu'elle n'a pas beaucoup aujourd'hui
encore on sait leur cité et dans une
usine de veolia en moselle on recycle le
plus de 90 97% de la batterie non
seulement la coque le métal les
plastiques mais on sait également
recyclé de dandé des métaux rares et des
matières rares allez je vous ai apporté
quelque chose dans ce petit flacon
du terme aux dates de lithium ouais pur
à 99 9% c'est exactement ce lithium
qu'utilisent les fabricants de batteries
neuves et bien vicieux qui est extrait à
l'autre bout du monde oui d'habitude des
mines en chine lou chili celle là elle
est extrait des batteries usagées les
premières dans d'autres villes de dieuze
en moselle donc on sait écrire le
lithium comme le cobalt comme le zinc
est comme les autres matières dont celle
seconde vie donc à tous ces matériaux
voilà ce qui est évidemment très bon
pour l'environnement par la planète oui
parce que des batteries en plus c'est un
peu lourd et c'est un déchet toxique une
batterie qu'on peut pas la laisser
traîner dans la nature comme ça c'est
très poliment si on veut stopper la
rareté de ces matières premières ou la
surexploitation des sous sols il est
important de donner aux déchets une
deuxième vie d'être informé en
ressources à celle en lithium cobalt
cuivre qui donne une batterie vous
trouvez tous à vos chères aujourd'hui en
plus ça oui le progrès et le lithium et
le zinc mais surtout le cobalt et le
lithium absolument r vous ambitionnez
être le champion européen là-dessus
issus du recyclage de la batterie
électrique du mans il ya beaucoup de
compétiteurs là dessus qu'ils se
positionnent pas encore en marche
aujourd'hui mais il est en devenir comme
cet amateur de venir il va y avoir de
plus en plus et c'est pour ça aussi que
veolia s'est associé avec deux
partenaires se lever pour eux la chimie
fine et la dernier stade de purification
de ces deux de ces métaux récupérés et
renault parce que renault sera un grand
utilisateur en fabriquant des batteries
pour ses véhicules électriques de ces
matériaux un petit mot de l'eau face à
la rareté de l'eau et ce qui vaut mieux
dessaler l'eau de mer ou recycler les
eaux usées et faut mieux recycler les
eaux usées pour deux raisons d'abord
parce que pourquoi pas les deux mon
général alors on peut faire les deux
mais quand on fait quand on réutilise
les eaux usées normalement on en a assez
puisque tout ce qui a été utilisée peut
être recyclé a2m raison c'est qu'il ya
pas de limère partout non plus et donc
y'a pas d'autres baer partout et ça
coûte surtout moins chère de recycler
les eaux usées aujourd'hui les eaux
usées sont peut recycler nos très peu 4%
dans le monde 1 % seulement en france
mais vous avez des pays qui n'ont pas
assez d'eau potable d'eau propre note
d'oddo non salées en israël par exemple
on recycle 90% des eaux usées mais même
en espagne on en recycle 18% en france
pas assez parce que euh on avait encore
suffisamment doute mais de plus en plus
on va y venir et pas seulement pour des
usages d'irrigation ou d'arrosage mais
également pour des besoins
d'alimentation des populations ou même
en cas de besoin de ultra purs pour des
usines qui nécessiterait une pureté
particulière
antoine frérot en matière de déchets il
ya beaucoup d'innovations aujourd'hui on
sait transformer nos déchets ménagers en
énergie quarante mille habitants de
l'île sont chauffés par l'énergie
produite par incinération de leurs
déchets et là on se dit qu'on est
totalement dans l'économie circulaire on
est au début de quelque chose là aussi
comment ça marche non on est déjà bien
avancé cette idée de valorisation
énergétique des déchets les déchets
plutôt que rien en faire autant en
fabriquer de l'énergie mais il est
encore plus intéressant d'en fabriquer
une nouvelle matière première et c'est
une réutilisation recyclage une économie
circulaire plus noble il ya plusieurs
manières fabriquer des nations était
déchets la première c'est d incinérer
pour détruire et tant qu'à faire de
récupérer la chaleur ou schmid et 18 et
de chauffer des logements des bureaux et
ça on le fait depuis longtemps mais il
ya une autre manière de faire aussi on
peut les offrir ses déchets dans
certains cas où c'est intéressant parce
que une fois aux fruits si le centre
d'enfouissement est bien conçu on
récupère le biogaz et habib beaucoup
d'endroits dans le monde où avec le
biogaz des décharges et bien on alimente
en gaz naturel des villes et des
industries et ça se fait de plus en plus
on a parlé beaucoup du méthane à la coop
veut 26 à glasgow en disant que le
méthane est un gaz à effet de serre
puissant on a les capacités de récupérer
ce méthane au moins sur des centres
d'enfouissement de déchets donc on peut
faire avec ces déchets à un carburant et
puis on peut faire encore mieux que
d'utiliser des accélérateurs on peut
aller travailler ces déchets non
recyclables et en faire un carburant
qu'on puisse stocker ce avec le problème
de l'énergie c'est souvent qu'on peut
pas là ce topic mai
eh bien avec des déchets avec des
déchets non recyclables on peut faire un
carburant spécifique qui est
renouvelable qui de toute façon et
mettrait en se décomposant des gaz à
effet de serre là en l'utilisant en
carburant on économise autant de
d'énergies fossiles qu'on a pas besoin
d'aller chercher dans le sol il ya un
type de déchets qu'on n'a pas évoqué oui
et qui est prometteur en matière de
recyclage ce sont les déchets organiques
les feuilles mortes les tontes de
pelouse les décès des restaurants des
résidus de déguster agroalimentaire en
faire quoi des engrais biologiques pour
remplacer les engrais chimiques et on le
fait déjà largement mais on va devoir
beaucoup continuer puisque les engrais
chimiques sa pro utilise beaucoup de gaz
de gaz naturel on peut l'économiser en
utilisant des déchets organiques et puis
un jour ces mêmes déchets organiques au
delà même des fertilisants on va les
transformer me semble-t-il en protéines
pour nourrir le bétail et ainsi
économiser des calories qui pourrait
être réservé aux humains lorsqu'il
faudra nourrir 10 milliards de personnes
on en aura bien besoin est les points
d'eau avec moi d'énergie avec moins de
sol sert même pas déforester viendra
bien besoin et la transformation
écologique vous savez c'est un enjeu
très vaste donc on a encore beaucoup
beaucoup pas inventé bon voila merci
d'arrêter avec nos antoine frérot donc
le pdg de veolia merci merci à vous
voilà c'est la fin de mon succès durant
l'émission qui rend les co-responsables
émission à voir ou revoir sur public
sénat où un replay sur publicsenat.fr
rendez vous dans deux semaines
[Musique]